So continuing to do and not as he says he
will do.
Donald Trump's 2019 deficit is on track.
[inaudible] the $1 trillion mark, despite
Trump having told us, you might remember time
and time and time again that he's going to
fix the deficit that Barack Obama ruined,
that he will pay off the debt altogether if
given eight years in office and the time that
he thinks he will need to do it.
Now, anyone who understands these issues even
remotely knew that it was never going to happen,
and in fact, it's getting worse and worse.
As I've said before, though, we really need
to be reframing our conversations about this
issue of debt and deficit altogether.
So let's start with the facts and then we'll
get into the analysis and the sort of meaning
of all of this.
The White House itself is now predicting that
the deficit is going to exceed $1 trillion
this year.
The deficit has never hit $1 trillion in a
year.
Now, anytime we talk about these numbers,
this is not a partisan, this is not to make
this worse or not as bad as it is.
This is just understanding when we hear the
deficit has never reached x number of dollars
before.
We need to understand number one, uh, inflation
adjusted numbers so that we're really comparing
apples to apples.
It's also important to understand the size
of the deficit as a percentage of the economies
total size and not in a vacuum.
Uh, just a few things if we really want to
do this seriously.
Uh, now let's go back to what Donald Trump
said that he would do when Trump was a candidate.
He said, number one, he would eliminate the
deficit altogether and he would get us a surplus.
Partially he would do it by cutting taxes
for the rich and corporations, which he said
would generate so much growth that government,
uh, ret tax revenues would actually expand.
And there would be all this winning and we
would have a surplus and we would start paying
off the debt.
Uh, that obviously never happened.
And it's important to understand, like if
you want to talk about this at all, I hate
that I have to do this, but you really need
to understand the difference between debt
and deficit.
Okay?
And I apologize to those who are sick of me
doing this.
But when I don't do this, and even sometimes
when I do this, the comments that I get in
reaction to debt and deficit stories are so
confused about the difference between the
two terms.
So these are not the same things.
Deficit is the one year, uh, a surplus versus
deficit that the country may have.
Debt is the accumulated deficits and surpluses
over time.
So let me give you an example.
If in year one of a country, you run a $50
deficit, at the end of that, the country has
accrued a debt of $50.
You exist for one year.
You ran a $50 deficit, your debt is now 50
bucks.
If in the next year you run a $25 surplus,
what happens at the end of that year is your
debt has gone down from $50 to $25 right?
Year one deficit is 50 bucks.
A year to surplus is 25 bucks.
At the end of year two, the accumulated debt
is $25.
You went $50 negative after year one.
And you paid off 25 of it with your surplus
in year two.
Okay.
I mean, I, I, I apologize.
Some people write in and they say, David,
please stop talking to the audience like they're
little kids.
That's not what I'm trying to do.
Every time I do this, people are confused
about the two issues.
So we were told that the tax cuts would pay
for themselves because they would generate
massive growth and they would move us from
having a deficit each year to having a surplus,
which would start chipping away at the national
debt eventually.
If Trump has eight years in office, completely
paying off the national debt, now none of
that stuff has happening.
Okay.
The tax cuts have added to the deficit increases
in defense spending, which by the way were
favored not only by Republicans, but even
by many Democrats as well.
Those are increasing the deficit and we are
not on track.
We're not on track to even pay off any of
the debt.
Nevermind pay it off completely in eight years.
So those are the facts.
Now, I do think every time we talk about this,
we should consider whether it needs to be
reframed.
And what I mean by that is the debt and deficit
is a political football.
Okay?
Republicans say the most important thing is
paying off the debt and balancing the budget.
When there's a Democrat in the White House,
regardless of whether that Democrat has actually
slowed down deficit growth, which Barack Obama
did when Republicans are running, they run
on promises to do this really important thing,
uh, start paying off a debt, generate a surplus,
but then when they are in office, as we saw
under George W. Bush, as we're seeing in a
cartoonishly exaggerated fashion under Donald
Trump, uh, they just explode the deficit.
And, uh, they always claim that they're doing
it.
They either deny that they're doing it even
though we have the numbers and that's what
we see.
Or they will argue that there were extenuating
circumstances whereby it made sense to a deficits
spend.
Like for example, when we decided we were
going to heroically spread democracy to Iraq
and, or punish Iraq for their non-existent
involvement in nine 11.
Right?
The reason we why it made sense to spend all
that money in Iraq changed once we figured
out Iraq had nothing to do with nine 11 but
still we were given reasons why it made sense.
So what we have today in the end is an unsurprising
status quo.
We were told before Trump was elected, what
he wants to do with tax policy is not going
to generate all of this winning and growth
and start paying off the debt with surpluses.
In fact, it's going to increase the deficit.
That is exactly what happened.
None of this is surprising.
So that gets us to the question of if and
how Democrats should talk about this on the
campaign trail because on the one hand Trump
made promises and he broke the promises and
he's doing the opposite of what he promised
to do.
It seems as though exposing that on the campaign
trail for the eventual democratic nominee
would be a worthwhile thing.
But on the other hand, we know number one,
that it's just a political football.
We know number two, that in reality, the narrative
over deficit, bad surplus, good cutting, spending
good or whatever else, it's not actually a
modern and nuanced understanding of debt and
deficits.
What we should be asking in reality is when
does it make sense for governments to deficits
spend and when doesn't it make sense?
So do we want to deficit spend to align the
bank accounts of the already rich and corporations,
including just providing money for them to
buy back stock?
The answer is no.
Do we want to deficits spend to improve society
for large numbers of people improve their
ability to live good healthy lives, have access
to health care work jobs that they like without
being tied to mediocre health insurance programs.
Okay, now we have something to talk about.
So I think that it is important for Democrats
not to ignore the issue of debt and deficit,
but we can't allow the right to continue framing
the narrative because they, when they talk
about it one way, when it's a Democrat in
office, they take office, then they just say,
oh no, the numbers aren't actually what they
are.
You can't believe the number, the numbers
that we're actually getting from the Congressional
Budget Office, uh, and from the treasury.
They win with the framing that we have, and
lastly, please, please, please, can we stop
falling for this stupid idea that tax cuts
for the rich are so good for the economy,
that they reduced the deficit and actually
increased government revenue.
We didn't even need another example.
We had plenty of examples before Donald Trump's
tax reform plan, but we can now add the Trump
tax reform plan to the list of tax cuts for
the rich and corporations that did not cause
so much growth that they paid for themselves.
My question to you is, do you think Republicans
even believe this idea that tax cuts for the
rich pay for themselves or do they know that
it's bs, but just keep repeating it because
these are the tax cuts that they want?
That's my question to you today.
Let me know
what
you think.